after weeks approached us against police
brutality Republican senator Tim Scott
is all set to unveil a plan later today
to reform America's Police Department's
a plan from Democrats is already making
its way through the house yesterday
President Trump
issued an executive order on this issue
but his critics say it is not nearly
enough Paula Reid is that the White
House was more on this story Paula what
does the president say about his plan
good morning to you good morning to you
too Gail well as you know the president
has been under enormous pressure to
address the public outcry following the
death of George Floyd yesterday he
signed this executive order saying that
it will improve police accountability
but it does not directly address racial
bias in policing or how to fix it
without police there is chaos without
law there is anarchy and without safety
there is catastrophe surrounded by law
enforcement officials president Trump
signed an executive order that
encourages police to implement best
practices like improving training
tracking excessive force complaints and
banning chokeholds except where an
officer's life is at risk but it's not
legally binding
Americans want law and order they demand
law and order they may not say it they
may not be talking about it but that's
what they want for more than twenty days
Americans have taken to the streets
demanding police reform but the
executive order does not make any direct
mention of racial bias or how to fix it
thank you attorney Lee merit who
represents families of victims and met
with the president at the White House
just before the ceremony said the order
wasn't enough I have to say it felt kind
of flat there was nothing in the
executive order that that my office or
these families could jump it the
president blamed the previous
administration for inaction President
Obama and Vice President Biden never
even tried to fix this during their
eight-year period but the Obama
administration did implement reforms
including banning the sale of some
military equipment to police and opening
over two dozen federal investigations
into law enforcement offices across the
country the
administration rolled much of that back
at a Senate Judiciary Committee hearing
Democrats blasted the order there is
nothing about what the president
announced today that would hold police
officers who break the rules and break
the law accountable the president
signaled he would be willing to work
with Congress on more significant
reforms and later today Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell and Senator Tim
Scott will hold a press conference to
discuss their own police reform
proposals
Anthony Paula thank you